- [Voiceover] Nightjars
possess a camouflage
perhaps unparalleled in the bird world.
So I guess nightjars are birds.
By day they roost hidden in shady woods,
so blank with their
surroundings that they are
nearly impossible to blank.
So before I even looked at the choices,
they're telling us that these
nightjars, which are birds,
they have a camouflage
unparalleled in the bird world.
So they're really good mixing
in with their background.
That's what camouflage means.
By day they roost hidden
in shady woods, so--
And so, I would say something like
so mixed with their surroundings
or maybe so blended
with their surroundings.
I'm not even looking at the choices yet.
So mixed or blended
with their surroundings
that they are nearly impossible to maybe
find or pick out, find or pick out,
or maybe even impossible to
or they are nearly impossible to see.
So those are the types of words
that I would try to look
for for these blanks.
And now let's look at the choices.
So this first choice, so
vexed with their surroundings
that they are nearly
impossible to dislodge.
So to be vexed with your--
So that's kind of angry or annoyed
or kind of worried or frustrated
with your surroundings.
Now that doesn't make a lot of sense,
that the birds would be that way
regarding their surroundings.
So this is already starting to feel weird.
And so vexed with their surroundings
that they are nearly
impossible to dislodge.
Well that means that they're kind of
so stuck into their surroundings
that you can't even pull
them out, if you wanted to.
So this one is feeling very wrong.
Let's read the next one.
So blended with their surroundings,
and that's actually the
actual word that I picked out,
so blended with their surroundings
that they are nearly
impossible to discern.
Well, discern really means to be able to
kind of pick something
out of its background,
to see it out of its background.
So it's very similar in meaning
to the words that I wanted to pick as is.
So this looks like the
choice that I would go.
This looks already like the best choice,
and we could read it.
Nightjars possess a camouflage
perhaps unparalleled in the bird world.
By day they roost hidden in shady woods,
so blended with their surroundings
that they are nearly
impossible to discern.
So that makes a lot of sense.
But let's verify that these
other ones aren't as good.
So, so harmonized with their surroundings
that they are nearly
impossible to interrupt.
So harmonize isn't a horrible word here.
It kind of means in sync with something.
So maybe they're harmonized
with their surroundings,
but nearly impossible to interrupt.
What are we interrupting them doing?
The interrupt especially is
what really makes choice C
really not appropriate.
So impatient with their surroundings.
So that already doesn't make sense.
I don't even have to read the rest of it.
So we could rule that out.
Distinguish actually isn't a
bad word for the second blank.
That they are nearly
impossible to distinguish.
That kind of has the same
type of meaning as discern
or pick out or see,
relative to its background,
but this impatient was
weird for this first blank.
So impatient with their surroundings?
That doesn't sound like how
we would talk about a bird,
a bird being impatient
with its surroundings.
So integrated with its surroundings.
So that's not bad.
That's kind of like
being mixed or blended.
Being integrated means kind
of so part of the surroundings
that they are nearly
impossible to classify.
So classifying something means
you're really kind of seeing.
You're putting a label on it.
You're trying to see how it's different
or similar to other things.
It's kind of like, it
has some connection to
being able to see something
or discern or find something,
but it goes further.
You're not only discerning
it or seeing it,
you're trying to kind
of put it into a bucket.
You're trying to classify it.
So if I didn't have choice B here,
maybe I could somewhat argue for choice E,
but the key to realize is
you need to pick the best choice.
So E is kind of a not horrible choice.
It's still a little bit strange,
but B is way, way better.
So we could rule out E as well.